[Music]
[Applause]
how long would it take for the world's
largest rainforest to burn down if we
don't do anything to stop it we'll soon
find out the Amazon rainforest creates
20% of the Earth's oxygen it's home to
30% of the planets species and it holds
the secrets to treating some of our most
deadly diseases if we destroy the Amazon
rainforest the consequences would be
disastrous and they'd be felt all over
the world could we survive without it
why would it have a giant impact on our
healthcare and would we ever be able to
bring it back this is what if and here's
what would happen if the Amazon
rainforest disappeared recently massive
forest fires have become the biggest
threat to the Amazon survival but
unfortunately the fires are just part of
a much bigger problem for example
farming mining and logging are already
responsible for three football fields
worth of deforestation per minute if we
don't do anything to stop this the
Amazon rainforest will disappear
eventually and we'd lose any chance we
have in the battle against climate
change
the Amazon rainforest is one of the most
incredible places on earth
it covers 40% of South America drives
the South American economy and stores 86
billion tons of carbon that would
otherwise be polluting our atmosphere
with an area that's this important you'd
think we would do everything in our
power to protect it but we don't
since 1978 an estimated 750,000 square
kilometers of rainforests have been
destroyed
all thanks to humans if this trend
continues the Amazon rainforest could
disappear within 100 years how bad would
that be for our planet well let's take a
look first starters we'd be losing a
huge amount of our planets biodiversity
the Amazon rainforest has more plant and
animal species than any other
terrestrial ecosystem on earth if we
destroy the Amazon
we'll be destroying all that diversity
too and wiping out an entire ecosystem
at the same time that would have huge
effects on earth we'd all quickly
realize how much we've been relying on
the Amazons resources for food and
medicine most people are surprised when
they find out that hundreds of
prescription drugs have come from things
in the Amazon rainforest we're not just
talking about simple herbal remedies
either we're talking about full-fledged
cancer fighting drugs that are so
important that they've been classified
as essential medicines by the World
Health Organization and we haven't even
scratched the surface yet scientists
estimate that they've studied less than
5% of the plants in the rainforest for
potential medicinal benefits so who
knows what other essential treatments we
could lose without the rainforest but
the most critical problem we face if the
Amazon completely disappeared would be a
faster pace of climate change if the
Amazon rainforest continues to wither
and die it will stop being a source of
oxygen instead it will begin to give off
carbon which we all know is fueling
climate change right now the Amazon has
a natural stockpile of carbon reserves
anywhere from 90 to 140 billion tons of
the stuff
if we woke up tomorrow and found the
Amazon destroyed especially by fire all
that carbon would be floating in the
atmosphere some experts believe that if
this happens
would lose the battle against climate
change but it's not all doom and gloom
there is still hope for the Amazon
rainforest through studies conducted
over the past several decades
researchers have found that tropical
forests may be able to survive human
caused destruction even without human
help a rainforest can start growing
again if it has enough seedlings however
this can only be successful if the
rainforest isn't always under attack so
what can you do to help
well for starters don't eat as much beef
processed beef products such as fast
food hamburgers are full of illegally
sourced beef from the rainforest reduce
the amount of paper you use and choose
renewable energy products whenever you
can renewable energy reduces the amount
of carbon we spew into the atmosphere
from fossil fuels many of which come
from the Amazon rainforest maybe if we
all work together we can restore this
beautiful rainforest to its former glory
but that's a topic for another what-if
[Music]